aufstellung zum offiziellen
mannschaftsfoto im dfb trainingslager in
eppan in südtirol
wenn ich noch irgendetwas
unvorhergesehenes passiert sind alle 23
spieler die auf dem foto zu sehen sind
bei der wm in russland dabei am tag
zuvor hatte bundestrainer joachim löw
seinen endgültigen kader bekanntgegeben
neben torwart bernd leno verteidiger
jahrhundert hunter und stürmer nils
petersen wurde auch die häuser nie von
der team letzte gestrichen
sany meldete sich inzwischen aus einem
instagram profil
natürlich sei er enttäuscht bei der wm
nicht dabei zu sein
er werde alles dafür tun noch stärker
zurückzukommen an die mannschaft
gerichtet schrieb er holt euch den titel
viel zeit zum testen bleibt der
deutschen mannschaft von bundestrainer
jogi löw nicht mehr
am freitag steht den leverkusen ein
spiel gegen wm-teilnehmer saudi arabien
an
am 12 juni reist das dfb team dann nach
russland am 17 juni wird es ernst im
ersten wm spiel der deutschen mannschaft
heißt der gegner in moskau mexiko